c'est l'attraction du jour au prêcheur
sous le pont les sept mètres de vide ont
disparu comblé par la coulée de boue de
la falaise sans père il ne reste plus
que quatre mètres nettoie pas qu un
poison mais c'est la timidité tous les
jours ça qu'il fait là hier soir ils ont
frôlé la catastrophe quand vers 21h un
nouveau l'art s'est produit pour les
riverains surtout ceux du quartier des
abymes le plus menacé le phénomène n'est
pas nouveau et les réactions sont
diverses
je suis parti avec mon père en prenant
tous mes bagages parce que j'ai eu très
très peur je suis allé voir comment
était l'état de la rivière vu la façon
dont que c'était et que tout le monde
était sur le pont tout le monde
regardait malgré les consignes qu'il a
donnée monsieur marcel à dos le maire de
pêcheurs personne n'avait et on avait
l'impression que personne n'écoute et je
n'ai jamais eu peur de la rivière au
contraire ça nous amuse et d'aller voir
de courir de revenir et ça ça nous
amusait aliette dessin des médailles à
force je n'étais pas du tout parce que
je sais ce que c'est j'ai toujours connu
ça après une nuit de surveillance les
techniciens de l'observatoire du monde
des cadets sont revenus sur place car le
phénomène est loin d'être terminée le
phénomène se poursuit puisque en fait la
falaise son père comme je le disais
continuer à s'effriter
il ya des pans de la falaise qui
continue à tomber et donc du coup qui
constitue une réserve au pied de la
falaise sans père et donc du coup lors
des événements pluvieux
ces sédiments seront mobilisés et qui
sont entraînés jusqu'au niveau du bourg
du prêcheur pour l'heure peu ont quitté
les lieux malgré l'injonction donné par
le maire hier soir outre le fatalisme
ambiant les prix chopin reste vigilant